this was the big uh story of the week
and i think it's pretty relevant tech
journalists
and uh the technorati uh went to war
this past week and um bellagi as you
know uh b-a-l-a-j-i-s
on twitter he worked at the um
andreessen horowitz there is
he's an expert on crypto and on
um biotech and
he was talking about how
uh people were not covering um
you know this story properly and a
reporter from recode who's only been
there for a month her name is
uh shireen and i offered her to be on
the pod she declined
uh balaji was going to come on the pod
and then he canceled on
us because kara swisher wanted to be on
the pod as well
and there was just a little bit of like
me and cara fighting for the same guest
uh and karen and i had been fighting
about this but the the tweet came the dm
came in and he published the dm
and we all get these from journalists
and the journalists have been pretty
negative and i just said uh based and
she said hey
we saw your tweets on top would you be
available to chat more about this on a
brief call
and he was sort of speculating that this
is going to wind up being
like another link his star link bait
historical story
so i wrote founders my advice is never
talk to journalists on the phone
you will likely be misquoted and your
answers will not be uh
as i should put little title there as
crisp as email there's so much gotcha
journalism link baiting
always use email and let the journalists
know you plan to publish your answers on
your blog this is my advice to founders
because the downside of talking to the
press today in this kind of very
negative environment is high
so uh cara swisher comes out swinging
as you would expect to defend her person
she's like oh please with the
with the dopey snark she's doing a great
story
um and um yadda yadda
then i go into it and um
you know terrorist fisher and i get into
we're friends we're gonna talk about it
in her podcast
long story short the story comes out and
boom the story no handshakes please the
tech industry is terrified of the
coronavirus
the the worst she literally said
you know we have this big debate that
this story is going to be link bait and
there's
all it's all downside for a founder to
talk to her and then she proves it to us
and then um bellagi
says incredible last week i called our
journalists who i thought was writing a
piece
that would be a disservice to public
health unfortunately my concerns prove
well founded
recodes virus peace ignores wh o and cdc
gets the science wrong and focuses on
the handshakes because here in silicon
valley people are saying hey let's not
shake hands by the way that's what
everybody's saying around the world this
is not unique to us
monique when you look at this craziness
oh and then by the way
bellagi then goes on to dunk in a tweet
storm
because he has yeah massive knowledge
compared to a writer a journalist has
five ten percent of the knowledge he's
going to have on the subject
by definition a journalist versus
somebody who like spends her time on
this
and he just fact checks the whole thing
and dunks on her monique
and you've been in the industry for a
long time like me a couple decades has
it ever been this contentious between
us and the press no this is the height
of
p contentious p contentiousness um
and you know i understand the media
business model
is sort of failing right now right and
so they need those clicks
and investors don't want to shake hands
is a much better story than the real
issue around coronavirus right right
um it's a much less exciting story um
but this is it's become really difficult
to talk to the press and i've had my own
issues with with the media and with the
press and
i was actually around the same time that
this was happening i was going to
make a tweet about a complaint that i
had about the press but it got so
people were dunking on the press too
much and i just felt like i felt bad
making it
um but people often reach out
um and ask you to make comments and you
know it's going to take
a terrible turn right right so you know
already that it's that it's
your what you say is going to be
misrepresented misconstrued
or placed into a story that doesn't
really give the full
the full weight of what you actually
said no contact um
so i think a lot of investors and a lot
of founders have rightfully sort of
pulled back from doing a lot of press
and are sort of controlling their own
media narrative
controlling their own story through
podcasting through writing through other
through other mechanisms and there has
to come a time when the press starts to
pull back
on this silicon valley is bad these
investors are terrible
these founders are kooky they don't want
to shake hands it's all becoming very
personal
and unnecessarily dunking on us yeah
and this and i don't have particularly
thin skin
no at some point it gets to be it gets
to be a lot and gets me very one note
it's nine out of f if you got ten if you
were contacted the last ten times by the
press
of those ten times how many times do you
think it was a negative slanted story
so many times seven eight nine seven
okay i was gonna say eight or nine yeah
and i always write back to them
this is the third time you've gone back
to you've uh
you know dm to me yeah because they
slide into your dm's like hey i want to
talk on the phone i'm like no i'll
talk to you you asked my question here
and it's always the same thing like
you know uber this this every and i said
do you want to
meet any of the 200 companies i've
invested in since uber
that are doing really important stuff in
the world because you haven't written
about blockable you haven't written
about cafe acts you haven't written
about lead iq you haven't been
written about ruby love can you do a
profile one of these companies that's
doing a great job
and you know as i tweeted tech leaders
are asking the tech press to take a
pause and ask themselves if they could
do better covering tech less
hysterically and negatively
which is very similar to what the tech
press as tech leaders to do over the
last couple years would just be better
and act more honorably both parties can
improve